today I will talk about hugging face and
how it integrates with Ray AI runtime
so before we start just a quick show of
hands please write in the chat uh just
wanted to know how many of you have you
heard of Ray how many of you have worked
with Ray and with hugging face or
Transformers in particular and how many
of you are data science or machine
learning practitioners so just please
write while I continue
so a little bit about myself so my name
is Anthony I'm a software engineer at
any scale I've been with any scale for
almost two years now uh I'm working on
the libraries team which means that I
hand the ray AI runtime and libraries
such as raytrain and retune and aside
from that I'm also an open source
Enthusiast and I contribute to and
maintain several machine learning
related open source projects
so a little bit about any scale any
scale is the company behind Rey an open
source unified framework for scalable
Computing and our mission is to make
scalable compute for AI and python as
easy and as robust as possible and we do
it because scaling is not is a necessity
and scaling is difficult and we want to
make it as accessible and as easy to use
as possible
so what are we going to talk about today
uh first I'm going to quickly introduce
a hugging face and how it can help you
with using cutting-edge machine learning
then showcase our distributed training
is a must in today's machine learning
environment and how you can make that
distributed training Easy by combining
hugging phase and array AI runtime or
array error then we'll Deep dive into
the internals of the ray airs hugging
face trainer and finally we'll conclude
with a live demo showcasing a typical
workflow you might do with the hugging
phase integration in Ray error
so just quickly to to recap provide some
context about the current state of ml so
as I hope we all know deep learning is a
state of the art especially for
unstructured data such as text Vision
uh there is also some progress in Time
series forecasting and so on and all of
this has led to some quite impressive
foundational models so such as gpt3 I'm
not sure how many of you had a chance to
for example play with the new chapter
GPT by open AI it's really impressive
and all of this
um this growth and this increase in
complexity uh of foundational models has
led to some very exciting use cases
especially in the natural language
processing and natural language
understanding category
so for example we have tasks such as
text classification sentiment analysis
entity recognition for example the names
in legal documents automatic translation
detection of toxicity in social media
sentence completion text to Mid
generation Q and A and so on and this
also has led to a necessity to fine-tune
those foundational models so that they
may be better
on the specific tasks that we want them
to perform
and aside from that the models
themselves are not only growing bigger
in size and complexity uh in the amount
of parameters that they have and the
amount of compute that they require but
the data itself is also growing bigger
and bigger still necessitating more
compute and more memory
and we are also approaching a point
where machine learning is pervasive
across all domains and businesses
and there are plenty of use cases for
machine learning that can improve
the business
so just to quickly introduce what is
hugging face so hugging phase is a
simple robust and Powerful library for
python which provides an opinionated and
high-level API
which wraps around various
state-of-the-art machine learning models
such as GPT bird and so on it's mostly
focused on NLP but there is also
some additional focus on audio
classification image generation and so
on
and most importantly it has a huge
community and social Focus especially
thanks to its hugging face Hub where
users can share and obtain pre-trained
models data sets and immediately apply
them to their use cases using the simple
and accessible hugging face apis
so how does hugging face make machine
learning easier so first of all it
abstracts away many complexities of
machine learning and deep learning you
don't really need to reason about the
underlying neural network architecture
you do not need to be an expert in
pytorch or tensorflow to take advantage
of all the state-of-the-art models that
hugging face
allows you to use
uh and because it provides a high level
of abstraction and simple to pick up
apis it also leads to Great developer
velocity meaning you can basically apply
uh whatever you you may require to your
use case right away and finally as I
mentioned there is the hacking face hub
from which you can obtain different
models and data sets so a typical
hugging phase workflow would be that you
obtain a pre-trained model then you
fine-tune it to your use case and then
you can use hanging face pipelines for
inference at scale so let's quickly
see a simple code example that
illustrates this
so first of all we use the hacking phase
datasets library to load a data set from
a hugging face hub then we split it into
a train and test data sets then we
obtain the model from hugging face Hub
as well which is the Barrett model and
it's already pre-trained and we may fine
tune it if we want or we can just use it
as is then we specify the training
arguments because we want to fine tune
it here
then we initialize the hugging phase
trainer object passing the model the
training arguments and the data set and
finally all we need to do is to call
train and hanging face text care of
everything internally
so even so of course those
state-of-the-art models they allow us to
do things that were not really uh
thought of in the past years but
the downside is that all those models
need a lot a lot of compute
so the problem is that
um
it is simply not really possible to
train or even perform inference at scale
on single machines so the amount of
computes required with each new
foundational model with each new
research breakthrough has been simply
outpacing the growth in Hardware
performance on a single note so of
course the Moore's law for CPU is simply
unable to catch up and even if we
consider Hardware accelerators such as
gpus if we were to train gpt3 on a
single uh on a single Tesla GPU it would
take hundreds of years
in other words since we cannot really
train the models and perform inference
at scale on single nodes on single
machines what we have to do is we have
to go distributed we need to scale out
horizontally but that of course brings
new problems so first of all our
developer velocity is going to
go down a lot because we need to learn
new apis we need to learn new libraries
that make
distributed computing possible we need
to consider new problems such as how to
communicate between nodes how to do
checkpointing effectively how to
transfer data between nodes
furthermore we need to learn how to
manage complex infrastructure when we
use a cloud provider such as AWS gcp and
Azure and now we need to learn new apis
we need to learn how to create new nodes
how to create new clusters and this is
all uh knowledge that is not necessarily
required for our core task which is to
take advantage of a fine-tune
foundational model or any other model in
that case
and finally even though we may succeed
in scaling up the training or hyper
parameter tuning or inference itself we
need to keep the entire end-to-end
machine learning pipeline scalable
because it's going to be as slow as the
weakest link and if we are unable to
scale up the entire experience
effectively then we are not going to
reap the benefits from scaling in the
first place
so the solution that we have created to
those problems is Ray AI runtime or Ray
air in short which is a scalable unified
toolkit for both data scientists and
software engineers and it provides a
flexible and pythonic framework for each
step of the machine learning workflow so
Ray air is the glue that holds together
different array libraries
and for example for data ingestion and
data processing you can use Ray data for
training we provide retune uh raytrain
sorry for tuning we provide retune and
for inference and serving we provide
reserve and Ray data again and Ray air
is a set of unified apis that make it
easy to transition between those
libraries
so if we take a look at the array or
ecosystem we can see that it is built on
top of Ray for open and flexible support
for ML compute from end to end Ray car
provides The Primitives on top of which
array AI runtime implements different
libraries and it leverages Integrations
storage tracking
and Ray air has high-level libraries
that make it easy for both data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers to conduct distributed
computing in their Ai and ml use cases
furthermore they are contains multiple
Integrations for all of the popular
libraries for different steps of the
machine learning pipeline allowing you
to keep using your favorite tools
without having to relearn new apis or
new Frameworks
so why use array in the first place so
first of all Ray provides an efficient
data layer and distributed object star
making data sharing between the nodes in
a cluster easy and seamless
array provides a python-based API
allowing you to write or all of your
code inside python
using pythonic conventions
and finally Rey provides robust
scheduling and Resource Management
including Auto scaling including the
scheduling of different of different
tasks on different nodes and it allows
you to leverage both CPUs gpus and
multiple other Hardware accelerators in
your tasks so in summary Ray provides
the compute straighta the infrastructure
management and solutions for the
challenges of distributed computing
so how do we combine hugging phase and
Ray
we do that with
the ray AI runtime stacking face trainer
so we have when designing the hugging
phase trainer we have aimed for maximum
Simplicity and to provide a familiar
interface that allows you to Simply
transfer your existing hacking face code
and run it in a distributed fashion so
first of all what we would do if we
wanted to use the ray air hugging face
strainer it would create a function into
which we would simply put our existing
hanging face code so this could be for
example what I have showcased previously
and the only difference is that instead
of calling
trainer.trainer at the end we return the
trainer object
then we provide the array air scaling
config which determines how many workers
we want to use and what sort of
resources we want to assign to those
workers so in this example we run the
training on three workers each with one
GPU and there are also other
configuration objects that you may use
that control different aspects of
distributed training then we initialize
the right errors hugging face trainer
passing in the function that we have
created the scaling config as well as
the data sets that we want to use
and finally the only thing we need to do
is to call defeat method on the hugging
phase trainer so as you may notice uh we
have been slightly inspired by
scikit-learn for rare because it
provides a familiar and well-known
interface
and it allows you to reuse the existing
hacking face code without having to
modify it in order to make it run in a
distributed fashion finally after the
training is completed the result object
contains data such as metrics the time
it the time it has taken for the
training to complete all of the
checkpoints that have been saved and
more
so if we take a peek under the hood of
the gray Air's hugging face trainer uh
what it does is it provides a way to
conduct distributed data parallel or
fsdp training on array cluster and here
we simply take advantage of the pytorch
DDP and fsdp implementations and the
built-in support for those in hugging
phase
it allows us to run user-defined hugging
paste code without any changes uh and we
automatically convert the ray data sets
about which I will talk a little bit
more in uh later uh to the format that
is expected by hugging face and it also
provides built-in logging and monitoring
uh with callbacks for different
Frameworks such as ml flow weights and
biases and so on
so how does raytrain conduct the
training
so the data set is charted between
multiple workers running on array
cluster each of those workers gets a
portion of the data set and conducts
data parallel training meaning that the
gradients are communicated and
synchronized
after the iterate after each iteration
if we want to change how many workers
there are in in our training ground or
what accelerators are being used we can
simply do that just by editing the
scaling config and this approach allows
us to abstract away all of the
underlying infrastructure meaning we can
focus on what's the most what's the most
important
so Ray air as a whole uses Ray data sets
as a common data format and Ray data
sets have several features that allow it
to work in a distributed setting so
first of all they provide various apis
to read from disk cloud or multiple
other formats Ray data sets are fully
distributed and they can be used on
array cluster without any special
considerations and they can also handle
data that is too big to fit in memory of
one node or even on an entire cluster
with thanks to the efficient usage of
the ray Object Store and objects
spilling to disk
uh Ray AI runtime also provides various
out of the box preprocessors for common
machine learning tasks and you can also
write your own user-defined functions to
map apply on rate data sets in a
parallel fashion
and the preprocessors are automatically
applied during training in inference so
here in this example we can use the
hugging face tokenizer inside our user
defined function and then we can use the
array data patch mapper
and pass it to the hacking phase trainer
and then automatically the tokenization
will be performed before the training
and before
inference later
so Ray air also provides multiple
Integrations for different logging and
monitoring tools there is built-in
support for tensorboard ML flow weights
and biases Comet ML and more and you can
of course use the Callback API that we
provide to tailor it to your use case
and the result object provides a simple
API to inspect the results of a training
run after it has concluded
in order to ensure that the training run
is robust uh Ray air conducts automatic
checkpointing during training which you
can of course configure to suit your
needs so for example you can only choose
to keep the and best checkpoints
According to some Metric
and you can also choose to save the
checkpoints to Cloud to disk and other
formats
you can resume the training from a
checkpoint object which is a unified API
for storing models and other artifacts
that have been created during training
and this automatic checkpointing and
automatic resumption allows us to take
advantage of Cheaper spot instances and
Ray air will automatically resume
training should a node be preempted it
will be automatically brought back up
and the checkpoint will be loaded and
the training will be resumed
and furthermore the checkpoint objects
that are returned after training can be
easily used for inference and serving
with other parts of the array ecosystem
so here is the typical hacking face
training workflow as I have shown before
and now what we'll do is we'll see how
we can easily change it into a
distributed workflow with Ray r
so first we just take the code that we
have that we have and we put it into our
new function
and instead of calling trainer.train at
the end we simply return it
then we initialize the array error
hugging phase trainer passing our
training function the scaling config and
the data sets so Ray data sets have an
API to automatically convert a hugging
phase data set into array data set
and then we just call trainer.fit
so to summarize we are using raid data
sets for ingestion which allows us to
efficiently Shard it across our array
cluster then we can use our existing
hacking face code we can for example
even take example code from the hugging
phase website and it will also work out
of the box and it integrates with the
rest of Ray r
so just to Showcase some of those
Integrations for example we can use
ratune to conduct hyper parameter tuning
we simply pass the hanging face trainer
into our array area tuner we specify the
search space and we call fit and the
tuner will conduct uh distributed
training and tuning
we also provide ways to do scalable
inference and serving with the returned
checkpoint object obtained after the
training we can pass it to hacking phase
predictor for scalable parallel offline
and online inference and under the hood
the hacking phase predictor uses hanging
face pipelines meaning that the output
is the same as with non-distributed
hugging phase but thanks to Ray data set
it can be applied at scale and in
parallel for both offline and online
inference with Reserve
so here is how we would use the batch
predictor from Ray R to uh do batch
prediction using the checkpoint returned
from hugging phase and we spec we simply
specify the hagging phase predictor as
the class that we are going to use the
task the hanging face tokenizer and all
we have to do is call predict
so now I have a quick demo showing off
a text classification
workflow using gray error and hugging
face let me see if I can
share it
sorry
not sure if this is sharing
unfortunately
okay there we go
so what I have here is I have uh jupyter
notebook that is running on a NSK
cluster so any scale is our managed Ray
service that we provide but all of this
can run with open source array without
any problems
so let us just connect to the ray
cluster and quickly see what sort of
resources we are working with so this
cluster has 16 gpus contained in four
nodes each with four gpus
and we will run our hacking phase
training using those gpus and with four
GPU workers per the training task so
this notebook is adapted from a
non-distributed hacking phase notebook
where we simply do a fine tuning of a
model and a text classification task
using the glue benchmark
for brevity I will just quickly skip
through the data loading part and the
pre-processing part but we are using the
hanging phase Transformer tokenizer and
we are using gray data sets to do the
pre-processing at scale I will also
limit the size of the data set so that
we can finish the demo quicker we Define
our pre-processing function and this is
the
main part where we Define the function
that will be run on every worker using
Gray
so we simply obtain the tokenizer and
model from hacking face Hub we defined
the training arguments
such as the learning trade the batch
size
and then we initialize the tagging phase
trainer and return it
and here we initialize the ray air
hugging phase trainer we pass the
function that we have just defined the
scaling config the data sets that we are
going to use in Ray datasets format
[Music]
specifies that we'll use the ml flow as
our logger the checkpoint configuration
and the preprocessor which will apply
the tokenization
and all we have to do is simply call Dot
fit
so there is some debug output but what
happens is that array will schedule
tasks
on our GPU nodes
and they will automatically start
connecting and we can already see that
it detects that Kuda is available
and now all we need to do is simply just
wait for training to
finish
so we provide Rich output for jupyter
notebooks so this table is automatically
updated as training progresses
and I have set it to run for to epochs
so we should see that the training is
completed soon
and at the end we'll obtain the result
object so we can see we obtained the
metrics reported by hacking face
uh the checkpoint object the directory
where the results are saved and so on
and now we can also perform hyper
parameter tuning with Ray R so let's say
that we have several learning rates we
want to consider for our fine tuning we
don't know which one minimizes the loss
the best so we can define a grid search
over those four different learning rates
and retune provides sorry to interrupt
uh we need to wrap up uh you have two
minutes left that's right that's right
okay so retune provides different
Advanced searching and scheduling
algorithms such as Asha for early
stopping
and finally afterwards we can do batch
prediction uh using the batch predictor
so instead of using the tuned
tuned model we'll use the one we have
just trained
so all we have to do is pass the
existing checkpoint specify the hacking
phase predictor and now batch prediction
will automatically commence and this is
the result so this is for a glue task so
we can see that the confidence score has
been returned and whether the
um text contains offensive or uh
non-offensive language and that
concludes the demo thank you so much